el periodismo pierde la mayoría en el
senado tras 38 años del regreso de la
democracia argentina las fuerzas
políticas cambian en el congreso-
millones de argentinos en todo el país
dijeron basta dijeron basta
el gobierno peronista de centroizquierda
pasará a tener 35 de los 72 escaños los
fernández tendrán que buscar coaliciones
al no tener el control del congreso voy
a dirigirme a los representantes de la
voluntad popular y a las fuerzas
políticas a las que representan para
acordar una agenda tan compartida como
sea posible
una oposición responsable y abierta el
diálogo es una oposición patriótica
nuestro pueblo necesita de ese
patriotismo
el gobierno enfrenta una dura crisis
económica con una inflación anual de más
del 40 por ciento una pobreza que afecta
al 40 por ciento de la población y el
desempleo que ronda el 10 por ciento
además argentina debe renegociar con el
fondo monetario internacional un acuerdo
con el que el gobierno anterior obtuvo
44 mil millones de dólares en
financiación la fuerza del ex presidente
mauricio macri gana asientos en el
senado pero tampoco tendrá la mayoría en
las calles los argentinos dicen que la
respuesta de las urnas es una clara
señal de cambio por un lado alivio
por el otro miedo la realidad paralela
que vive en vigo nacional
porque están festejando la derrota a
pesar de la prevista derrota en las
urnas fernández mantiene el control de
la cámara de diputados lo que deja con
vida al peronismo